[Música]
y es por eso que yo quiero invitarles
invitarles ahora a que ustedes se tomen
un par de segundos en olvidar lo que ha
sucedido antes y en liberar la
expectativa por lo que va a pasar en
algún momento más
situarse en el aquí en ahora es algo
factible por eso yo le he puesto a este
a este mecanismo a esta posibilidad la
apelativa o el nombre de la doble a el
aquí y el ahora
te invito les invito a que se vengan al
aquí y al ahora y una forma muy rápida
de hacerlo para que podamos cerrar la
tarde y poder crear de aquí en adelante
un mecanismo que nos permita decir oye
he invertido muy bien un sábado de mi
vida es traer tu mente al lugar donde ya
está tu cuerpo traer tu mente al lugar
donde está tu cuerpo en este instante y
si cada uno de ustedes toma su índice de
la mano derecha así como cuando vas a
acusar a alguien todos si tú también eso
y lo pones sobre tu nariz sobre una de
las cosas de tu nariz
y haces
una inspiración profunda
y luego sueltas ese aire y hazlo
te vas a dar cuenta de que por algo
estás aquí
hazlo como si te gustará es decir como
si de eso dependiera tu vida si lo haces
por una tercera vez hazlo de nuevo a ver
y luego exhalas absolutamente todo para
cerrar con la otra mano levanta tu otra
mano
y haz lo mismo por favor es decir toca
tu fosa nasal izquierda y
y nada solamente por la derecha algo de
nuevo yo lo voy a hacer contigo pero te
invito a que lo hagas porque sabes voy a
necesitar de ti en todos y cada uno de
los 14 minutos que nos quedan de acuerdo
y luego exhalar libérate de ese momento
porque ahora sí ahora si quisiera que ya
que estamos en el aquí y en el ahora nos
hagamos la pregunta de fondo
para qué te sirve tu ombligo
tiene una respuesta porque yo me he
venido haciendo hace mucho tiempo para
que te sirve tu ombligo es más yo sé que
tu nariz te sirve para una función vital
hasta tus pestañas te sirven para una
función vital tus cejas tu cabello o tus
dedos tus manos ni que decir de las
piernas absolutamente todo lo que está
en tu cuerpo no está por casualidad
tiene un propósito si para qué te sirve
tu ombligo
no me digas para poner un piercing porfa
no es cierto porque esa es otra harina
de otro costal para qué sirve tu ombligo
entendamos obligó como la cicatriz que
te queda luego de que han separado tu
conducto umbilical de tu madre
amigos yo me he hecho esa pregunta si me
he hecho esta pregunta una vez y la he
vivido he vivido dando vueltas porque
por mucho tiempo no encontré la
respuesta pero aquí viene la respuesta
hace tres o cuatro años cuando mis hijas
estaban en la peor de las pubertad es
que se puedan imaginar si se me vino la
bellísima idea de poder hacerme un
tatuaje un tatuaje que me permita no sé
de ponerme un poquito en onda a ver para
qué sirve mi cuerpo tratar de ubicarlo y
había identificado en la parte de la
derecha de mi cuerpo el lugar donde me
lo iba a hacer un tatuaje no sé si
porque estaba de moda o porque mi cuerpo
me lo pedía y bueno cuando se lo comenté
a mi esposa me dijo estás loco esto no
se va a poder hacer porque tenemos hijas
en edad escolar es decir estaban de 14 y
15 años aproximadamente y que si lo iban
a hacer si lo ibas a hacer tú
y a mí como su padre que crees que iban
a ser tus hijas y te cuento que yo el
otro día que he visto su tablet hay
fotos de tatuajes o sea que ellas
también están explorando la misma
posibilidad que tú si tú lo haces das
pie a que algo más suceda entonces
postergue la idea como padre responsable
que creo que soy sin embargo hace poco
tiempo me traumatólogo me dice que tiene
que operarme y me tiene que operar de
una pequeña lesión que tengo en el
hombro y me dicen no te preocupes te va
a quedar una pequeña herida no es cierto
te va a quedar una pequeña herida y una
cicatriz que para eso va a pasar no te
preocupes lo vamos a hacer y al día
siguiente vas a poder retomar sus
actividades saben el rato que me lo dijo
el momento en que me lo dijo yo dije que
tenía la coartada perfecta para poder
hacerme el tatuaje tú imaginas y ha
cerrado el círculo verdad lo que pensé
en ese momento es claro voy a tener una
herida y voy a tener que cubrirla
y como yo voy a tener que cubrir la y tú
no entonces esa era la estrategia
perfecta para que mis hijas no se hagan
el tatuaje y yo sí bueno me hicieron la
operación me hicieron la cirugía y qué
creés varios meses después cuando al
salir de la ducha se me ocurre revisarla
para ver si ya era el momento para
hacerme el tatuaje o sorpresa me acerco
a verla frente al espejo no había tal
cicatriz la cicatriz si acaso si acaso
se veía imperceptiblemente y en ese
momento no sabía si maldecir al médico
que la hizo o agradecer por mi gran
poder de cicatrización
realmente me di cuenta en ese momento de
que la estrategia tatuaje con herida no
era una posibilidad y dije bueno chau
plan tan está pintando elucubración no
va a ser posible de realizar entonces lo
que hice en ese momento fue reencausar
el plan y dije que otra cicatriz puedo
tener y qué crees ahí desnudo como
estaba frente al espejo encontré una
cicatriz la cual me había estado dando
vueltas por la cabeza durante mucho
tiempo ya sabes cuál verdad mi ombligo
mi ombligo y me hice la pregunta la
pregunta de fondo que hoy he venido a
responder con ustedes para qué servirá
el ombligo si no es para poner piercings
pues yo creo que a partir de ese momento
me di cuenta de que en ese mismo momento
les quiero aclarar simplemente que me
metí a mi google en mi teléfono así
desnudo como estaba y encontré de que
hay un par de casos en los cuales hay
personas a las que se les ha disminuido
la abertura dominical a tal punto que
casi no se nota casi no se nota pero
está ahí se dan cuenta no es que ha
desaparecido o se ha perdido es el caso
modelo y de una atleta pero no existen a
nivel mundial casos de cicatrización y
desaparecimiento umbilical entonces en
ese momento cuando veía a mi bellísimo
ombligo recuerdo de una conexión muy
directa con mamá me di cuenta de que mi
ombligo estaba ahí con la posible misión
de recordarme a diario y cada que lo vea
algo que yo tenía que hacer y ser ya te
estás imaginando que es verdad ir por la
vida ir por la vida en una actitud de
pertinente y permanente de buscar
conexiones o sea no se me imaginaba y yo
yendo por la vida con mi línea de porque
si saben que esto se llama la línea de
vida verdad para todos los que hayan
trabajado alguna vez en altura o han
hecho algún deporte de riesgo es algo
que se llama life line o línea de vida y
que pones firmemente a tu arnés que
casualmente está ubicado en el sector
umbilical y que me recordó y me
respondió me ayudó a responder la
pregunta que me había hecho tu ombligo
está ahí para que cada que te lo veas
te recuerde a que tienes una tarea
pendiente cual es conectar con alguien o
sea creo que la actitud a partir de ese
momento cambio y la actitud es ir por la
vida en esta actitud algo así como con
el mosquetón abierto para decir a quien
me conecto y qué creen
tú no vas a conectar con cualquiera es
más todos vamos por la vida tratando de
ver a quien conectamos y hay gente que
no es elegible
y para esas personas la posibilidad de
liderar no es una posibilidad
me van siguiendo hay una idea detrás de
esto quiénes son los que son capaces de
liderar sostenible y sustentable mente
pues aquellos que son capaces de
conectar oye yo me imagino que si yo
iría por la calle acá en la avenida
américa trabajando con mi mosquetón para
ver si puedo enganchar a alguien te
aseguro que hay personas me dirían que
yo estoy un poco loco sí y evitarían
corporal o fisiológicamente mi contacto
sí pero que tendría que pasar para que
ellos me digan si se le conecta me que
tendría que pasar tendría que haber una
especie de explicación de por qué estoy
haciendo esto casi a dónde voy mira te
cuento de que es mi línea umbilical y no
es que quiero que seas mi mamá pero me
gustaría que seas mi amiga no es cierto
algo así tendría que hacer pero esa no
es nuestra posibilidad de pronto
aparecen un par de ideas en la mente y
dicen oye la gente ya está buscando
conexiones hay dicen si quieres llegar
lejos anda solo o perdón dice si quieres
llegar rápido camina solo pero si
quieres llegar lejos que te sugieren
te sugieren andar con alguien y mejor si
es en una acordada en una cortada
acordada significa cuando yo punto uno
mi punto central mi punto móvil y carl
al tuyo y así caminamos una jornada
jornada que puede ser de un día entero o
de una hora hoy este concepto está
siendo presentado en muchos otros
aspectos es más cuando tú te casas con
alguien te ponen una cuerda o un lazo
cuando tú caminas con tu niño pues le
pones un lazo y de una u otra manera las
personas que quieren mantenerse unidas
crean una conexión crean una vinculación
pero ojo no todos somos conectables o al
menos decidimos de una manera consciente
o inconsciente no serlo no ser
conectable han visto o han escuchado
este refrán que dice cómo te veo te
trato en la paz es muy popular y mucha
gente ha pensado de que se trata de la
pinta con la que tiene que ir uno por la
calle de la percha de la de la ropa de
la forma en la que te venga fuera yo
creo firmemente en que esto no es cierto
creo firmemente en qué
por la que vas con la que vas por la
vida define te hace conectable o no si
el término conectable es entendido yo
puedo pasar al siguiente
durante algún tiempo estuve con esta
duda en la cabeza con estas ideas dando
vueltas porque yo hago esto siete días a
la semana para mí esto que estoy
haciendo en este momento no es un
trabajo no es algo fuera de mi contexto
es algo para lo que he vivido para lo
que me he preparado y esta señora les
guste o no esta señora para mí
representa la que me ayudó a cerrar el
círculo de lo que he venido a contarles
hoy día ella se llama rita person es muy
conocida por una charla ted que dio hace
10 años atrás yo la comparo
personalmente con él
jaime escalante boliviano sí es una
profesora de unas comunidades en
dificultad y creo que al decirnos lo que
acaba de decir o sea ella dice las
personas no los niños no aprenden de
personas que no les gustan ella dice
kingston learn from people they don't
like
y ustedes deben tener mucho más claro
esto si las personas los niños no
aprenden de personas que no les gustan
entonces a mí me ha dado la respuesta
que yo estaba buscando aquí en conectó
sólo a las personas que me caigan bien
solo voy a ser capaz de conectar a
aquellos que son hacen su esfuerzo por
caerme bien y desde esa perspectiva
alguien quisiera proponerles como
posibilidad el hecho de que no digas oye
yo soy así
dale conecta me sino más bien encontrar
la posibilidad de crear un vínculo con
el otro producto de los cambios que
puedes hacer en ti y es por eso que yo
le he cambiado me tomado la libertad de
cambiar eso a un ámbito mucho más amplio
no creo que sean sólo los niños sino
todos nosotros los que aprendemos y nos
conectamos sólo a personas que nos caen
bien y esto es algo que el ser humano
sin necesidad de entrenamiento previo
hace y es por ello que yo lo vínculo
directa y tremendamente con el concepto
de liderazgo entendiendo de que el
liderazgo no es una posición sino es una
acción y esa acción es la que te permite
junto con otras personas un sueño un
proyecto una idea un emprendimiento o
simplemente una vida feliz porque te
aseguro que si estamos acá es porque
hemos concebido en algún momento la
posibilidad de ser felices en esta vida
y les aseguro no solos hay alguien hay
alguien que está metido a lo mejor tu
pareja a lo mejor tu perrito a lo mejor
tus padres tus hermanos o alguna
comunidad una comunidad con la que
trabajas por eso yo desarrollo cierto
tipo de alergia cuando las personas
dicen voy a hacer mi emprendimiento voy
a desarrollar mi proyecto por bolivia
oye tú y yo hemos debido encontrar
personas que dicen eso y esto no tiene
sentido porque nadie puede dar lo que no
tiene y al dar lo que no tiene está
diciendo que voy a hacerlo por bolivia
que le vas a dar primero tienes que
tener tú y desarrollar cierta base para
que luego pueda estar en forma de
impuestos en forma de aportes como sea
necesario o en forma de trabajo trabajo
que tú estés dispuesto a hacer
quiénes son las personas conectables con
esta pregunta hoy excepto las personas
conectables son las que desarrollan un
modelo de seis patas espaldas
entendiendo como patas cada uno de los
componentes del nuevo modelo del
liderazgo en acción del liderazgo basado
en conexiones estas personas que
desarrollan cualquiera de estos modelos
desarrollan cualquiera de estas
actividades o un balance adecuado de
estos de estas cualidades son aquellas
que son conectables entonces se puede
resumir diciendo quién es más conectable
aquella persona que tiene una
combinación muy adecuada de estos seis
factores una combinación muy adecuada de
estos seis factores e incluso para
mejorar el entendimiento de este modelo
yo propongo que al menos desarrollados
así como el saltamontes tiene seis patas
es cierto pero por lo menos
únicamente dos de esas seis patas le
permiten saltar bien lejos entonces si
este año que recién comienza tú
necesitas o tú te propones desarrollar
por ejemplo tu autoestima y tu actitud
mental positiva pues esas que sean tus
dos patas de fondo ellas te van a
permitir desarrollar un concepto que he
tratado de poner en una sola frase creo
yo creo yo que desde alguna perspectiva
bolivia necesita de este tipo de líderes
líderes conectables personas que estén
no sé haciendo cosas como lo que está
sucediendo en este proyecto no sé si se
han dispuesto a pensar un ratito si tú
vas a una biblioteca que es lo que sacas
sacas un libro consultas un libro miren
este proyecto este proyecto me llamó
tremendamente la atención porque vincula
perfectamente con lo que estamos
haciendo acá qué pasaría si en vez de ir
a una biblioteca y sacar un libro irías
a un lugar donde tocas a una persona y
esa persona viene a charlar contigo
desde su perspectiva y experiencia
personal esto es lo que busca este
proyecto
esta capacidad de conexión con alguien
que desde su propia perspectiva te
cuente algo de su historia pero esto no
podría ser posible si es que no hay
personas con disposición a escuchar esto
no podría ser posible porque imagínate
tú bazán a sacar un libro porque quieres
leerlo te vas a sacar a una persona para
conversar con esa persona si tienes la
voluntad de escucharlo por eso te invito
a pensar oye estás dispuesto a trabajar
sobre estas preguntas
bolivia inspirarme a crecer es un
concepto que realmente nos ha permitido
ponernos a pensar sobre estas y otras
preguntas pero yo te cuento te digo de
que este es un espacio solo para gente
fea ok por qué digo fea porque son
personas a las que vamos a escuchar
aquellos líderes felices que construyen
y motivan y con eso conectan entienden
life la segunda es la gente de acción
gente de acción que con su acción y no
con su queja demuestran ese camino y fin
las acciones que muestran los ejemplos a
seguir a esas personas si les vamos a
decir amigo amiga inspira me a crecer
muchísimas gracias
[Música]